talk to me about the future of Dance  Moms now that Maddie is not gonna be  around really well no you know I create  stars I have my kids in I think 17 18  different Broadway shows so it's what I  do  is to make these professional working  employable dancers who can go out and  get a job and get a job in and I pride  myself on that I've taken so many kids  out of Pittsburgh and onto the Great  White Way in New York City and right  into a Broadway show out here in Los  Angeles like kids working in different  television shows in the movies video and  everything and so she's just another one  of those kids that I think I'd proven my  talent with you must be super proud I am  I am I'm very proud